And I wanted to welcome you all to a very special topic and something I wanted to do for a pretty long time, which is talking about associations. And it's a super cool, it's a super obscure topic, and I find it amazing because normally you have to read a lot of books from Jung.
And this is, let's say, my unique selling point that I said, okay, I read all the books and then I collect all the information when Jung talks about, for example, synchronicities or dream interpretation or individuation.
Because Jung does not define things normally, he just mentions them in the side sentence and likes to let phenomena and ideas interact instead of just defining them. But in this case, it's pretty easy. There's one book, there's one book about associations. It's pretty thick in German.
It's Experimentelle Untersuchungen, and in English it's Experimental Researches, which is a very dry title to a very dry book. It is very thick because it's basically full of tables, and it is interesting because I completely stumbled upon this and I never heard about it before.
And it's in the very dark part where people normally don't go for Jung because it's not very shiny. It's not very flashy like Dreams or Aions and all these things. This is in the early parts of the Collected Works. And anytime when you go somewhere and you see this question like, oh, what should I read about Jung? Or I want to read the Collected Works.
Most people say, yeah, start with book 5, Symbols of Transformation, the book that laid the foundation for the Jung that we know and love. They say, where are the first 4 books? They are early, uh, Jung's life and They're, they're very dry, they're very academic, and they're not as interesting. So many people skip them, but I wanted to read everything. I did not skip it.
And when I read it, it blew my mind because it's super, super interesting. This is Jung in his early life, fresh out of university with his PhD, trying to make a name of himself.
So he came to a facility called Burghölzli and they took care of people with psychological problems like schizophrenics, psychotics, and other people who could not function in their normal, normal life anymore.
And he would do, of course, try to help them, but also do research because this field of psychology was very new. It was a little bit bleeding edge and the newest science. Uh, so it was very little known.
There were not really overarching models or theories or even standard procedures how to explore this field of psychology, to how to explore the psyche of people.
And this book with all its contents is Jung the scientist establishing himself through experimental research, academic research that was published and also made him famous. At that time in the US, even more famous than Freud in the beginning.
And it is based on a very simple idea and a phenomenon that, that, that was observed with people with psychological problems, for example, neurotics, uh, or hysterics that when they were being told a word and be told to give a reaction, that they would take a longer time than normal people, people from the street.
And this was not discovered by Jung. This was discovered before, but Jung took this concept and ran with it. And the whole book is about him exploring this concept, this phenomena.
And finding out so much stuff and really taking certain ideas, concepts, phenomena, and blow them completely out of proportion and being obsessive with them and trying to explore and map them and formulate them.
And this is mirroring what he will do later with this archetypes or Aions, where he's going very, very far with very simple concepts, seemingly very simple concepts.
So what we are talking about here is what we would call today differential psychology, the psychology of personality, because if you want to map the personality of people, the question is how you do it.
And the way how to do is just by measuring differences between people, This is why you have most measurements like personality tests and tests of cognitive ability, for example, that they're never really absolute. They're always referenced against something, and this something is a group of people.
If we, for example, stay with general cognitive ability, also IQ test, known as the IQ test, there's always that you measure a group of people. And you take the median of it and you say that is 100, and then you reference the people to that 100 so that they're 110, 120, or 80 or 90. But there's always not an absolute value.
It's always in reference to the group because when we're talking about personality and having differences between people, like someone is aggressive or someone is friendly, there has to be some kind of reference point. And this reference point is other people. So we are looking at how different are people in what regard, like how do they react differently?
And this phenomena that was well known back then and which Jung investigated was this of, I have a stimulus word and I try to get a reaction word. So I put something in and there comes something out, out of the patient in this case.
This is similar to when you have, for example, you use sonar, what bats are using or boats on the ocean. And if you want to see what's below the surface of the water, what's down there on the ground, you send an impulse, a ping. You can also hear it in the submarine movies that the ping, ping.
And this is like a standard thing. It's always the same thing being sent out, but depending on what it hits on the way, there will be a different response. And this response can you tell if there's something, for example, for a bat, if whether there's the wall of the cave or if there's potential prey or a predator or something else.
So while this thing going out is being standard, The thing coming back is unique. And what happens there, we cannot see. It's a little bit like a dark lake, right? Or total darkness for a bat. And we construct something out of this reaction.
And what Carl Gustav Jung really saw is with this phenomena of these associations that people have is you can take the same word, give it to different people, and they will react in different ways. And he said, this can be the foundation to explore the personality and the psyche and a lot of other things about that person, because this reaction is unique to the person.
It's something individual. And yeah, this is why I want to do this, because as I said, it's blown way out of proportion. And there's a quote about it. I want to tell you. Association experiment. The emotional content usually concerns things that the test subject would like to keep unknown to the other person.
It is usually something embarrassing and therefore repressed content, even content that is unknown to the test subject himself.
When a stimulus word encounters such a complex, he cannot think of an answer at all, or he thinks of so many things that he does not know what to answer, or he repeats the stimulus word mechanically, or gives an answer and immediately replaces it with another one, etc.
If after the experiment is completed, the test subject is asked again how he answered the individual stimulus word, he can usually remember the usual reaction words well, but the complex words are usually difficult to remember. So there's really a lot in there. And let's construct this.
I just want to read you a list of stimuli words, stimulus words that Jung would give his patients because there's like, like a standard form that people can use at home. And so it's a mixture of different things that are neutral and other things that more likely to get reactions out of people.
For example, the first one is hat, then green, water, sing, death, long, ship, to count, window, friendly, table, to question, village, cold, and so on. And you roughly have 100 to 200 words.
So you would sit down with the patient and just read them the words and tell them, okay, What's the first thing that pops into your mind? Give it to me. And Jung would write this down and he would not only write down the reaction word, or sometimes not even a word, but the, let's say the reaction of the patient. But he would also write down the time.
So he was a Swiss guy 100 years ago. Of course, he had access to a lot of good watches and he would write then down, okay, how long does a patient need to react to something? And the genius thing about this is not doing this list, going through, writing down the time, writing down the reaction word, but rather to do it twice.
So after the patient completed this, you do the same thing again. And Jung noticed something very interesting, and this is what he then investigated. It is when people answer quickly. To a stimulus word and they were able to reproduce it in the second run. They would say the same word again. Let me try to get a reference.
It's a full, the whole book is full of it. For example, pain. And the reaction was because I'm sick or tired. I am tired. And Kaiser Wilhelm. And these short reactions, they would work. And they could be repeated.
But the interesting thing is when a reaction word needed a longer time, the patient were not able to repeat it again. They would say a different word, and especially the longer the time is, the reaction shifted suddenly. And this is also what he talks about in the quote. The person suddenly gets distracted by something.
There's something stirred in their psyche that prevents them from having an immediate reaction. So if we stay with the bat, the wall, there seems to be free field, free field, free field, but suddenly it's, ah, there's something in the way.
And this reaction, where Jung said, we hit something in the psyche that prevented the person from acting normally. And he would call that a complex. Not at this time, this was not known yet. But he said there's something preventing the person and reacting in them.
And he would then investigate this further and further and further because he noted many, many effects. As I said, he really was obsessive about this and noticed a lot of things because if you do the same thing again and again, you suddenly find out differences between people. And this is what I found interesting, how different people react.
For example, some people liked adjectives, some people gave nouns. And one big thing that Jung noticed was these associations. So the connection between the stimulus word and the reaction word. And he noticed something which he called inner association and outer association.
An outer association is something which is very superficial, even abstract. It doesn't even have to make sense. For example, words that rhyme: mouse, house. And he noticed that people, for example, when they're very sick or very tired, or when they're drunk, under the influence, would like to choose these outer associations.
And these inner associations, they're more connected through meaning. For example, when the stimulus word is sun, the people would react moon. So there's a connection there, but it's more connected through meaning. It's not obvious through the word. So it's traveling somewhere in the more semantic realm than the phonetic realm.
And one would think, okay, yeah, just give a reaction, give a word. He noticed that people reacted differently as they would give full sentences sometimes. For example, they would define suddenly the reaction word. Just as I read from the book is sick. Ah, because I'm sick. Or dance. I like to dance.
Also giving like a statement about themselves or sometimes even using quotes, uh, just quoting things that are popular in in culture or at the time, or just like proverbs that people use in colloquial language or metaphors of, of language.
And he would look at this and also take into account the background of the person.
So, 'cause as I said, he wanted to find a difference between, okay, what differentiates a normal, healthy living person that have their normal life, they can interact with have stable relationships, have a stable life, to another person who cannot take care of themselves anymore because of psychological problems. What is the difference then? Can we measure the difference?
Because it might not be so obvious, but how can we really quantify this? This is a scientific part. How can we quantify that somebody has a problem? And can we maybe define a tool that makes it possible to define what their problem actually is?
Like a questionnaire or inventory to say, okay, this person is bipolar or schizophrenic or catatonic, to already make a categorization to then of course start the therapy, which is then suited to them. And this whole book really is basically about that.
You have tables over tables of stimuli word, reaction word, time. Where he then goes into explaining it. And there's, if you're interested in language, there's a lot of linguistic in there to define what, what words are and what sentences are and the different ways just people, how they can react. But this is only the first step.
The first step for Carl Gustav Jung was of course getting measurements, getting results, but also then as a next step to find where are the differences between people. And he could find out really a lot. For example, he could find out the degree of education from people, and that was an interesting one.
So you might think, I've told this difference between inner associations and outer associations, outer associations being the phonetical stuff and inner associations being the meaningful stuff, the semantic stuff. If you might guess, if you have educated or uneducated people, who would prefer what?
The interesting thing is he noticed uneducated people, Switzerland 100 years ago, would prefer the inner associations. That means to have a connection of meaning. Also to answer in full sentences and statements and being a little bit more colorful about their reaction. And his idea was really, okay, they are more connected.
They're trying to connect the word really to a larger context. He said, for them, a word does not exist independent of something else outside of a context system. And he said, for educated people, this is something different.
He said, And those breaks were always very short and then also very abstract, a little bit lifeless, we would say, like the inner associations being full of life and the outer associations being cut off like a piece.
And he could see then that in his investigations also, he could see differences in, in men and women, how they would react to certain words. And yeah, what I've mentioned, like when people get tired or when they're sick, there was a, this shift then of the reactions.
But the reaction that he was most interested in was really that of this delayed reaction. And there he noticed a lot of interesting effects. So stuff you cannot think about until you see it. For example, people would sometime have kind of delayed reaction. So this is very fast-paced. This is word, word, word, word, word.
But he would notice that sometimes these reactions for the later words that came later also expanded the time, or people would get a reaction to a word that came up earlier. So there's like a delayed process happening that is startling people and they have to catch the drift again.
And these would be then the words that he would use to diagnose the people because you have to kind of find out what their, let's say, problem is.
And in the quote was also that he talked about, it could be a secret that people do not want to talk about, or it could be a secret that is so secret that they do not know about, which is then in the unconscious and a staple of psychoanalysis or analytical psychology.
So through these echoes he would send out, and through these measurements, he would hone in onto specific topics, and he could then read in this, for example, if people have a problem in their family, with their partner, with their childhood, with their sexuality, because they would react to certain words in this way.
And by having so many measurements and to reference it against other people in similar circumstances, you can then see really the differences. And he would start to see more and more. For example, he would start to differentiate really personality types. And he said there's this kind of judgmental type that comes up.
So when they get a reaction word, they would give like a value statement on it. They would say good, bad, or they would use a lot of adjectives. And because he tested so many people, he started to see patterns. For example, he would, he said that at a certain age, this judgmental type came up more and more at different times for men and women. So this is one of the differences.
Like he said, oh, the judgmental type for women roughly starts with 40. And for men with 60. But as people get older and older, they get more and more judgmental in their personality. But then he said also, oh, we have this abstract type.
So people who are really, let's say, intellectual about their reactions, and they have more nouns and things that are separated, short words. And he would then continue down this path and map out more and more, and it would expand more and more.
So he then would start not to only check the patient, but also the people around the patient. Like, okay, let's do this test with their parents, their children, their partners. And then he would start to see all these connections also. So he could figure out relationships through these tests.
For example, he said, when there were daughters, their reaction type was very similar and their, their answers to their mother up until the point when they left their childhood home and got married to a man. Then they would start mirroring that of their husband.
And he said, like, husbands, they don't change their reaction type to their spouses. But suddenly he could see these differences of, of children and their parents and their relationships and how this would change over time.
So with his simple, I give you a word and I get a reaction, he could suddenly see a lot of personality relationships, stuff that is hidden to the patients themselves. And this, all this, what he published.
Laid the foundation for him to get into contact with Freud, because at that time, this idea of the unconscious and of complexes was not so well defined. So Jung had all these measurements, and he could not completely make sense of it because he only had, like, the phenomena, but he did not have the theoretical groundwork for it.
And then he stumbled over Freud, and Freud had this idea about complexes and the unconscious and so on. And Jung read it and said, oh my God, this, this hits it completely. What Freud is talking about, I measure.
So he would get into contact with Freud and out of that, very deep friendship developed for 6, 7 years until it broke apart, uh, because they had some fundamental disagreements about, uh, psychology and how the psyche is construed. But Jung was a huge proponent of psychoanalysis and Freudian psychology because it could explain all these things that he's had measured.
And Jung, as he is, went further with these tests. And at a certain point, he realized a biological effect that might make reaction words or reactions in general superfluous.
In the sense of he noticed or found out somewhere that the conductivity of the skin changes based on the reaction. That means if you have a low electrical voltage and you measure it on the skin of the patient, that you could measure the change of conductivity. This has to do with like how moist your skin is. And this is a very quick reaction.
For example, when you start sweating, when you are afraid. And here he could also get the reactions without recalling the answer and the time and so on. And I read this and I thought, wait, you, you are asking people questions and you're measuring their skin and you find out whether they are trying to hide something. This is a lie detector.
Jung came up with a theoretical foundation for a lie detector, and it, it completely blew my mind when I read it. So yeah, we can credit Jung with that because this is how a lie detector works without words, but with electrical current.
And he became famous for that, as I said, and then was approached later even as a kind of criminal investigator. So this is cool. So he would, the, like the police. Would contact him for certain cases.
For example, when people got murdered or something was stolen, where he would do these kind of reaction tests on the, the suspects and get confessions out of them. This, he does this several times. He even writes about it in this book. So basically like a living human lie detector.
But this has a very tragic end, his criminal investigator career, as he basically got someone arrested and incarcerated who didn't do it. He had a weird profile and Jung said, oh yeah, he definitely murdered his wife. And years later it was found out someone else did it.
So the guy became free and Jung did not really want to talk about this topic and stopped basically this whole side gig that he had there.
This is also not so well known, but he continued with the association experiment and the measurements he did there for his later research and life's work in, in general.
So all the things I talked about, like, okay, there's a differences in men and women, how they react to stuff, Like, oh, the, the daughter is closer to the mother and the wife is closer to the husband. He would then investigate further and came up with this concept of Logos and Eros, right?
For this being connected to others and to the outside world, or being more on the path of separation, to be separated. Logos and Eros. Eros being more of the relationship function, Logos being the differentiating function, the separating function.
And these reaction types of the judgmental type and the more intellectual type would lay the foundation of his ideas about introversion and extroversion, and for his whole typology that he would publish decades later and became pretty famous for, as Jung created the first model of characterizing personality.
With introversion, extroversion, thinking, feeling, intuition, sensation, inferior function, superior function, which was later used in the Myers-Briggs Inventory, MBTI, which then again laid the foundation for a lot of the ideas for individuation and how people change and how people should change to become a complete human being.
Jung always built, and this is why you can read the early stuff to understand the later stuff, because he never threw away really an idea or concept or phenomena. He always tried to combine those things and let them branch out.
So while the association experiment itself is only really mentioned in this book and maybe some, some letters or seminars on a very short notice, you can feel the influence through his whole life. Life's work. For example, what he does in the talking cure and therapy is basically the same thing.
Freud also did this, like, oh, tell me about your mother, tell me about this, tell me about that. So the material comes out as a reaction from the patient and gets investigated by the therapist and the patient together. So there's a reaction. Okay, why do you have this reaction? Like, why, why do you have an association there?
How do you come, when I ask you this, that you come up with this. And this is the connection that is unconscious, and there might be something in the background. So the whole idea about complexes being in the unconscious is then built around that and how to investigate them. So he would watch his patients when he, they would talk and suddenly they would stop talking.
There was something coming up in the back of their mind and he said, aha, this is a complex. There's an unresolved issue. Let's talk about that. Let's investigate that. And he worked like this his whole life, investigating the complexes, like what are the things that could cause trouble in you that you're not even aware of.
And an important part is also, also then in therapy as a diagnostic tool, dream interpretation, because Jung was a huge proponent of the interpretation of dreams, same as Freud, even though they had very different styles of interpreting the dreams. The idea is the same, like the patient dreams of something which is hyper subjective, which is a dream.
It's, you can't get more subjective than that because you're the only thing there that can experience them. And they're unique to you because they come out of your psyche. They're like all these reactions coming out of you, but you don't know the stimuli word. They are just a reaction to something, but you don't know exactly what they're reacting to.
And this is why he would use it in therapy to get then, okay, yeah, you dreamt of this. Why, why do you think like, okay, what you, you dreamt of a fairy grandmother, like what are your associations with a fairy grandmother? And he would use these associations always as building blocks and steps to move through this completely unknown territory of the unconscious.
And to explore it together with his patients. And I have a quote for the dream interpretation: Dreams don't exactly repeat an experience. They always have a meaning. They are actually like an association experiment turned inside out. In these experiments, we have stimulus words that strike the complexes and elicit it to emerge, whereas dreams themselves produce the test words.
Dreams bring up a system of stimulus words that refer to the underlying meaning. If you emphasize these words and certain motives that often recur in dreams, it is really revealing when you ask, what comes to your mind about this? And this is how Jung sees the psyche in general and personality in general. It's not something separated. This is not only a test.
It's like your reaction is always individual. And it's not only that you react to words like that, but you react to everything in a specific individual way. He said life itself is one big association experiment. You're bombarded with certain stimuli, but how we react is then individual.
And this always can give you an insight into yourself and how you're built up internally, all the stuff you have not paid attention to and should pay attention to. And this is what made me really, really interested in that because it, it clicked.
When you read Jung, you have a lot of confusing stuff hanging together, and sometimes you get this insight because you have enough material. And then it is a little bit like a murder mystery where through the movie you have all these clues, and in the end, there comes a twist and it's revealed and everything falls into place. It's like, oh, this makes now sense.
And this experience really I had when I read this book, because I read it pretty late, because everywhere I read that you should not even read it at all. So I thought, okay, let's read this fun stuff. And this was also fun stuff.
As I said, a little bit dry, but when you, it's like Alchemy, also very dry, but when you get the idea what he means and why he's interested in that. Then it becomes really exciting. And this is why I do this Jung Helpdesk meetup group to say like, oh, there's those ideas, look out for those stuff. And then you understand why is he constantly talking about reaction words?
Why is he constantly talking about alchemy or astrology or different other things like religion, mythology? Why, why he talk about always these, these topics? But in the end, everything is connected.
And for him, it connects all through the psyche and the associations are a fundamental thing that is happening inside the psyche that can tell us something about ourselves and about our lives. And that would be it. That would be my presentation for the topic, the exciting topic of the association experiment. And I want to thank you very much for your attention and for your time.
This would conclude my presentation part, and now would come discussion part with where people can give feedback or talk about other things like synchronicity. I saw here in the chat. So thank you.